we begin with a dramatic turning point
in the fight against Isis us back forces
in Syria this morning are celebrating
the defeat of Isis in its former
stronghold of Raqqa there are multiple
reports that the city has fallen
fighters from the Syrian different
democratic forces are dancing and they
are chanting in the streets losing Raqqa
is a major blow for Isis the group once
called the city its capital Holly
Williams is inside Raqqa with the
military gains and the challenges still
ahead Holly good morning good morning
from our name circle in the very heart
of Raqqa this place used to be an
ordinary traffic circle but then Isis
turned into a place where they carried
out public executions they posted the
evidence of those horrific killings on
the internet now our name circle was
retaken by these us-backed Syrian forces
last night and yesterday we witnessed
them on the streets of Raqqa celebrating
they were in a victorious mood after a
four-month long battle it is a bizarre
feeling to be here because during the
three plus years that Isis was in
control of Raqqa if I had somehow made
it into Isis territory I would almost
certainly have been taken captive and
very likely killed now there are thought
to be Isis fighters still lurking and
building in buildings and in tunnels
here in Raqqa and it could take months
until the city is finally cleared of
explosives that were laid by Isis then
they will somehow have to find a way to
rebuild this shattered city where there
is hardly a building that is unscathed
some buildings like this one over here
have been left to pulverize by fighting
others like the one behind me have been
flattened by US airstrikes nearly all of
the residents from Raqqa perhaps all of
them have now left the city and many are
in refugee camps it is a terrible irony
that in order to retake Raqqa from Isis
they've had to destroy it
gaile that is ironic but very big day
there thank you very much Holly Williams
reporting from Raqqa